I wonder if you notice any connection
between the 1 2 3 4 numbers we've got on
board you can look at it
diagrammatically but you can also do the
calculation between for example these 3
together this have a thing what's the
link between them how come combine these
3 numbers to get this last one
hey girl what the numbers are they
values and then look at the diagram well
you ready yeah fantastic if you take
these two very close I think I know what
you need but I wonder if you add these
together when we get you get 16 right if
you let the 16 and subtract away or this
number what's this this is the
intersection right we take that 16 and
subtract the intersection what we are
not with is it's nothing like that but
first let's write that down and then
we'll explain what is right so if we
take these two separately there's those
two numbers 7 plus 9 and then we
subtract the intersection what we get is
the total number in both circles right
why don't we have to subtract why isn't
the group of people the set of objects
in a set of objects that they just add
together to get a me they'd all be I
should say why don't I do a subtraction
yeah the Dalai Lama sitting figure out
who's not actually yeah yeah you're very
sweet weekend so it's the overlap isn't
okay right so maybe losing that this way
imagine if you've got all these waters
going out from the kitchen okay and what
someone wants to know is pretty people
are actually killed 18 subjects right
well if I said okay well I've taken
seven orders for apple pie I've taken
seven orders for apple pie right and
then someone else says well I take my
orders or baby you added them together
why is it wrong to conclude that there
are 16 people I've got 16 one is we've
fulfilled six a month and 60 people why
do I have to subtract one again you're
right then but why is this is not
necessarily 16 y/o orders is not the
same people because people can have more
right in other words what we did was we
can turn these orders you got seven then
you can turn these ones you've got right
good luck to see this five here you
don't counter them does that make sense
so this dotted line here this is
indicating I want to remove my double
counting and that's okay all right yeah
I think I understand it's just a couple
of tiny bits of notation this time and
then we're just going to use it
sometimes we want to describe who's
inside each of these sets of eyes to a
little wolf finally so for example I
would say where is the I can say Johnny
I could say they belong to say so now
this is me thinking about focusing on an
individual object rather than under set
as a whole
Cymbeline used is the Greek letter
epsilon so this is um I can't remember
if it's an upper or lowercase I think
anyway looks like an A except you would
write it as a city every - so don't
don't write like this that's something
different okay so this Greek letter
epsilon its it indicates here it means
is a member all that's the way you would
read right
Johnny's a member all the people who
made apple Podge I would say at the same
time well Johnny's not a member of B
right so the way I would write when I
have something in maths you know when
you say something is and if you say
actually these two things these two
things I'm not people ready to do the
equal sign they just been lining through
right so we do the same thing with this
we would say Johnny we put the is a
member of civil and then we put a line
through it right yeah it doesn't belong
okay now once you've got this idea of
want me to miss em or that said probably
now even though it's not so relevant to
probability if I can think of a better
opportunity to mention remember I said
to you before a set is any collection of
objects right any questions you like but
it matter of often interested in order
to talk numbers
yeah so there are some particular sets
related to numbers that are really
important and I'm going to
NASA that you will recognize it later
when you see them okay I'm going to do
them in this order let's do so these are
some really single so these double lines
through them to indicate something I'm
going to give you all the symbols and
then I'll describe to you what each one
means okay so these four things here are
special sets and we often use them into
a math sets of numbers the first one is
an M because it stands for natural
numbers these this is a fancy name for
just all the numbers that you count one
two three four five and so on we call
them natural because they're actually
you carry they're everywhere as soon as
you stop counting things you've got no
fingers on this end you might have seen
importance they don't know what a stands
for I'll give you a clue it does not
stop with this or whether stops and said
anyone might have seen this not into a
textbook in some way on things said is
for the integers and you might wonder
why is it his head with a German word
which is about all of us so when you
think about integers we mean all the
natural numbers 1 2 3 4 5 but we include
a few more which ones do we add on say
we save integers so we're including
those so we said 1 2 3 4 we could have
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 there's one other one in
between the positive numbers that are
they did numbers what's in between them
I guess in between I slide shows a
person I guess in between 1 & 2 & 3 & 4
would you have the decimals I'll come to
those in a second but others it's just
like 1.5 is an integer it's not right we
mean holnar bistec that that's why we
call it into just like
integral something that's for the number
of speaking was 0 0 is an integer is
okay this cute this stands for the
rational numbers do lot of plans and why
is it acute can anyone think all when
you take Russian up season fractions
right what number to Jewish
that's where thank you what number to do
dislike what words to envision what
sounds for the cubes question right
thank you
so this set of numbers here are all of
the artists questions but what happens
when you divide numbers by each other
said 3/4 of 100 or 110 all of these
numbers belong in the rational numbers
so these guys in addition to these and
then the last one
thankfully this one does stand for these
look real numbers right and on we've
talked about these anytime you were
solving for example a quadratic equation
and do you remember if you accounts one
might say is this equation young right
is how people look at it if I handed you
that equation and last you sold it right
you'd have some trouble okay you have
some trouble because number one can you
factorize that easily that's like it
doesn't it doesn't like to factorize so
then what would you do when you can't
baptize a quadratic wait what's your
other before you use them all you want
to deal with that equation right see -
baby but then when you try that it
explodes in your face because when you
try and do the minus B plus or minus
this part here this part yeah you get a
negative under there does anyone
remember what do you intend to write
afterwards Oh entities what's the thing
we teach you I don't know we tend to
write no real solutions we don't mean is
not solution typically we actually need
either a technical sense right so these
include irrational numbers certs things
like that and a few other ok one very
last name I probably don't want you to
tician but this is what you actually
know about we just need to notice it
before when you're working out
probability for example have a look
again in this situation yeah I could say
what's the probability that it was so
that someone who didn't eat anything on
this list
okay well they call thats answer the see
when you were looking at a group of
people are you looking offices of those
all the rest of them so you want to
remember that's all its that again yeah
we call the company or the compliments
and this passage is one person do we
call them a compliment now when you have
a look at these sets here we have kind
of not one not two but three ways to
describe the compliments so if I want to
say they're confident I'll we said but
when your door is let's talk about apple
pies you would take that set there and
you would do one of three things either
you can put a bar over the top so I'll
read that as everyone who didn't get out
the client or you would put a again
because I'm still interested that
newsprint - you can tell the people who
may have this notation didn't do very
much work in calculus because we use
dashes for something else but sometimes
you see that and you need to know in
this context that's what needs and
there's one last one people are talking
about compliments they're like well
let's see sometimes you see a tiny
balloon
see up there it's everything and
frequently used that blast was noticed I
think you will see them in this order
the most common one which oh you've got
a bar over the top but all three appear
in the silver says why I'm telling you
about okay